today on our show we are gonna talk
about three things that are awesome yeah
I'm one of them is gonna make you Thor
you'll need a bonding agent to make it
all better
oh my god I got nothing and a third
story because me forced to down your
throat
today on fat man on Batman
that men on Batman well the fat man
Batman I'm Kevin snow monkey okay yes
let's talk about x-force why wouldn't we
talk about exports Drew Goddard the
Martian and he may he wrote the Martian
Germany he made a cabin in the woods
mm-hmm he made daredevil yeah he was the
creator he gets created by credit and
wrote the first goal of episodes has
been tapped to direct direct an x-force
movie now he was tapped to direct a
sinister six movie few years ago when
Andrew Garfield was smarter man but that
went away now Fox has tapped him to do
an x-force movie but what's special
about this x-force movie is two of the
main characters of this x-force team
movie are Deadpool yup and cable who's
being introduced in Deadpool too so my
lord
Fox just stepped up their game they're
like hey we invented the superhero team
movie so this is what we do we're gonna
do it again and this time maybe it's
r-rated they might make it aren't rated
you think I mean if you're gonna put
Deadpool in it and clearly it is not a
barrier to box office tough to pull back
the reins now I wouldn't you that's
right so that's happening who's in it
um well aside from those two guys we
talked about they haven't really
mentioned who the cast the roster would
be it's a black ops team next force in
this iteration show they're doing
Suicide Squad I mean yeah yeah cuz you
can you can you can say more Deadpool
that's good good for me and Deadpool
taking a what do they call ensemble
mm-hmm as opposed to like look at me I'm
the middle no he'll be the Will Smith
yeah it really is [ __ ] suicide
totally but and they've got a bunch of
x-men stuff coming down the pike they
have let's see x-men New Mutants I want
it coming out next April wanna Deadpool
2 is next June wanna and then x-men Dark
Phoenix is next November who's directing
it
that is Simon Kinberg himself all right
I want it yeah so next year we already
have three three installments of the X
Universe the xxx year ladies gentlemen
dirty that's what that means sales like
2019 will be when we get to see x-force
mofford fantastic good friend
or x-men movies and yeah look they got
it down though science they don't need
Marvel help over there man it's a shame
but it's the way it is but Marvel don't
need their help man they got Thor coming
ladies and gentlemen the floor is about
to happen Ragnarok and this looks like
one of the most joyously
comic book comic-book movies ever made
seems to embrace its kooky origins and
stuff and not kind of like let's
normalize this name spaceships [ __ ]
the eyes garb if we're gonna hell up I
forgot Valkyrie my [ __ ] revenge errs
team I know that's kind of dough because
he's fantastic and they were spending
money on it I mean maybe they launched
the new trailer during the the NFL
kickoff game last night yeah I need a
[ __ ] cheat box that's not cheap but
they got all the money in the world
because they got that [ __ ] immigrant
song on you know that ain't cheap they
Pony DUP Disney potent it up for Led
Zeppelin was the director's name taik
iike white tea tea funny which i just
like to say yeah that's fun name but
funny like this movie looks like fun
like i mean it's a crime in crime is
ridiculous to be like oh this looks
better than the first two Thor movies
[ __ ] yeah it does this is but this is
this is just in a whole different place
altogether man like this is totally this
looks better than most movies period not
like oz looks better than the last to
Thor's they're taking Thor and putting
into a whole new place
I mean taken throw or through a whole
new door thank you and they're putting
in space like Thor in space is the
bridge to guardians of the galaxy coming
back for Avengers infinity war and they
say there's gonna be a Guardians cameo
right in in Thor Ragnarok and if you've
seen if you've seen the the the footage
that came out of both I mean Helicon
Indy 23 they showed like a teaser for
Avengers infinity war which opens with
you know the in the Milano the [ __ ]
guardians of galaxy they run into [ __ ]
Thor like on the windshield of that ship
so like yep what's that I don't know
turn the wheels your wipers we got to
get it off oh I can't wait so yeah like
I'm totally that's what this is doing
like this is a comedy it's a buddy
comedy ultimately yes and it feels that
that is the thing that also helps to
sort of nip the Tuck
into what Guardians is and then bring
that to him back into the main molding
universe and a back to her Hulk movie as
well yeah I love the fact that they've
decided and it makes all the sense to
know where the Hulk doesn't actually
need his own movie no it's not that
they've decided he doesn't need his own
movie it's just like they can't they
can't do a solo Hulk movie because
Universal still has the rights to do all
the solo hope so they're like we can't
do one we'll just stick him and [ __ ]
every other movie we get and the
character is actually better served by
being a foil to other people I would
agree with that I think their hands
being tied from doing a Hulk would like
look in the hands of anybody you know
great material can come forth but I
think he's I think do this yeah while
let him be in other people's movies with
people like I love the Hulk til it's a
fever pitch and then you do your old
blue then you sit down at the table with
Universal or whatnot look all right
let's do it but they don't even need to
Marvel's no Kevin Feige got figured it
out he's like [ __ ] second Hulk and
Thor and Ragnarok their bodies they're
having a good time by themselves getting
after it that movie looks phenomenal I
read something online I want to talk to
you about so holla is the villain yes
first female Marvel villain in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yeah
played by Cate Blanchett one of the
greatest actresses on the planet legit
serious [ __ ] actress technically the
collective chick from guardians to would
qualify as an antagonist at the very
least which won the gold-plated lady
from the collective yeah yeah yeah but
she wasn't a bad guy in fact they were
the bad guys because [ __ ] rocket
stole their batteries right but then
they show up I mean once you try to kill
the heroes then you become defective the
bad guy but I think that'll be the
asterisk on that little sentence give it
to Cate Blanchett would you [ __ ] I'm
sorry Galadriel so Kate block is the
baltics dog she brings out her horns
like this and [ __ ] in the trailers looks
awesome
looks like she's enjoying a [ __ ] at it
oh and dad now that line which we've
seen in trailers a lot is she's on the
goddess of death and all that [ __ ]
somebody said online I don't know this
is and again I don't remember if I read
on tweet or somebody in a legit article
or something like that
conjecture
that you know fan oohs whoo although all
about the Avengers infinity war all
about that day in the comics he was he's
always trying to impress lady death so
he'll kill universe is to impress death
who he's fallen in love with there's
some talk that hella they're gonna drop
the lady death and its hella that Thanos
is trying to impress well and that hella
she ain't one and done and Thor she'll
be back in Avengers and the infinity war
I don't know if there's any truth to
that but I like that very much I like it
way more than them introducing like
here's lady death and [ __ ] yeah play
with the character you already got bring
Kate Blanchet back and tie those movies
together this smells like something that
the Marvel team Kevin Feige would do I
hope it's true I hope that conjectures
truth and honestly like the Marvel
Universe needs another good villain
I mean they've they've linked so hard on
Loki as the one that worked and he's now
a good guy and now he's a good guy like
basically they make all their villains
you know kind of cojiro is like Winter
Soldier was the villain you know so it's
like they needed another giant baddie
and if it's gotta be Cate Blanchet you
know who is one of the best actors on
the planet
not a bad pole she's fantastic it's just
from the trailer alone I hope this is
true I hope the Avengers the two movies
involve fan oohs want to impress Hera in
some way maybe that's what brings him I
don't know look I had the writer I just
like watching this [ __ ] hell yeah but
that's exciting to me
I don't you order this Thor movie like
you [ __ ] read about I'm not alone
I've read an article where is like the
most anticipated movie of the fall is
Thor Ragnarok you ever imagined you'd
live in a world where somebody's like
the most anticipated movie is a Thor
movie it's amazing in the right hands
anything could be like and there are
people now who are asking what is what
is Ragnarok mean let me tell you let me
explain it to you
there's also I've read an article about
how if you've seen the trailers so far
that you haven't seen any lady SIF or
the Warriors 3 but they're saying don't
be fooled by that there is there's news
about them I think it has to do with I
think maybe they get [ __ ] killed
as guard maybe I mean lady SIF bad
actress she's on the cast list like
they're in it I think she's in the movie
I don't know mother but if hell is
coming and she's like ask god it's dad
like somebody's got to die and that
would be that make Thor real mad he'd
kill lady SIF and the warriors three
hell you kill anyone tor gets upset I
can't wait to see what's it coming out
November like early November 2 got all
the money let's talk about
Jimmy bond yes mark just dropped some
information so James Bond is is maybe
the last thing he's a sensitive man I
believe those are the lyrics James Bond
is maybe the last great free agent as
far as franchises go why free agent
because James Bond belongs to a
production company belongs to ion
production zone by the broccolis so he's
not owned by a studio not owned by a
studio has no real studio affiliation
Studios can enter a contract to a
relationship with that production
company and Sony has for the longest
time the last like 15 years been the
home of Bond before that mgm/ua and then
they went out of business Sony got the
rights the rights are are expiring and
so after the next Daniel Craig movie
which I believe have a name for but it's
bond 25 it will be up for grabs for
grabs in every studio in Hollywood wants
it because these movies to make money
they make money I mean Skyfall and you
also like you can like it's not just
Daniel Craig's like you stick anybody in
there you can place your bond every few
years you make a new franchise and it
becomes a big it refreshes it's this
continual money-making machine
nobody is bored of bond yet apparently
not so there are a bunch of suitors you
know paramount once a piece of it I'm
sure Disney would like to get in that
business because Disney collects
franchises like I collect pounds
sterling
oh I'm palm drop you never know where
it's gonna go it's like a triple
entendre talking after it and so now the
two new bidders into this project are
Amazon
an apple Apple is the most surprising
[ __ ] thing in the world why they have
got all the money and the house that
we're making content now they're making
content but they've never made
theatrical content in any way I can't
imagine there's a weather which bond
would only exist on Apple devices true
because that is you know for going I
don't think you make a billion dollars
on a movie buy all the movies are the
sexy it's not essential but it's a nice
commercial for yes to the movies life
you know and some of the executives at
Sony especially the TV side have just
left Sony to help form Apple's new TV
division yeah could you imagine we're
living in a world where Apple might own
James Bond I mean or Amazon and [ __ ]
maybe throw Netflix into that Park
they're not bidding yet but they've got
all the money to they've got all the
money to like it and it's the last great
like we said the last great unattach
franchise the broccolis would still
produce barbara broccoli and Michael
Wilson her husband take me over for
cubby broccoli who originated it back in
the 60s but it's it's a whole new world
we're streaming Giants would it be in
the bond business well it's it seems
like all these streaming Giants or I
mean never mind the old studio system
this is this is gonna command the future
Apple Amazon Netflix Netflix they just
announced they're gonna be losing
remember they lost all the Disney
programs like Marvel movies and Star
Wars they're gonna be fine right now
they took those as well
Disney's like you know what we're
yanking that [ __ ] to her own streaming
services starting in 2019 it's
competitive man and Disney's like look
we ain't getting left out of this we're
not taking a piece of Netflix when we
could like create our own streaming app
and they've already got it and you're
look at Disney on demand or what and
apparently it's pretty good you know and
doesn't cost it's not a backbreaker but
as we talked about before every one of
these $4.99 5 99 $7.99 will at some
point add up to $200 you're spending a
month on way more you spend on cable
right now pretty much yeah man Disney's
going digital on the big bed way took
him a minute but now they're like we're
all in they're going digital with their
sports they're going app with everything
else like that's the world we live in at
this point pretty much so I wonder what
happens we'll keep an eye on James but
we will indeed imagine you wound up at
Amazon
so like he'd [ __ ] Daniel Craig could
be like you know I'm on her Majesty's
Secret Service
but if you're looking for good service
there are low prices on this Amazon Day
sale boutique coming right now and they
would call the movie prime directive
Amazon's prime directive starring James
Bond dude there it is folks
that's all the news we got for you man
not now let's talk about our week what
do you got that's that
Hey look at all this [ __ ] we did talk
about a bunch of [ __ ] analyze some stuff
yeah and make some [ __ ] up too come on
tell us about it yeah let us know write
to us at the address that's not real
listed below yeah I'll keep doing the
hand thing is it's gonna be up there but
it's never gonna be there well yeah it
ain't happenin say nope
ah that's it we'll be back with more in
the next episode until then for fat man
I'm Batman I'm Kevin and I'm mark
barnard tune in next episode same fat
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith see I'm
not gonna point anymore i point all the
time it's not pointing to anything maybe
should be over there maybe should be up
there with it [ __ ] it's believing
believing without a dream I believe
[Applause]
remind how we used to be everybody
searching for no we were gonna do round
two we're done we're done
[Music]
you
[Music]